>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Eni Jucja: Ladies
and gentlemen,
if I could please
have your attention
for the national anthem
of the Republic of Albania
and the national anthem of
the United States of America.
And the anthems will be
performed by Lindita Lole.
>> Lindita Lole: [Singing]
"Rreth flamurit te perbashkuar
me nje deshir' e nje qellim,
te gjith' atij duke iu betuar,
te lidhim besen per shpetim.
Prej lufte vec ai largohet,
qe eshte lindur tradhetar,
kush eshte burre nuk frikesohet,
po vdes, po vdes si nje deshmor!
Prej lufte vec ai largohet,
qe eshte lindur tradhetar,
kush eshte burre nuk
frikesohet, po vdes,
po vdes si nje deshmor!"
[ Applause ]
[Singing] Oh say can you see
by the dawn's early light,
what so proudly we hailed at
the twilight's last gleaming.
Whose broad stripes
and bright stars,
through the perilous fight, o'er
the ramparts we watched were
so gallantly streaming?
And the rocket's red glare,
the bombs bursting in air,
gave proof through the night
that our flag was
still there Oh,
say does that star-spangled
banner yet wave, o'er the land
of the free and the
home of the brave!
>> Eni Jucja: Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> H.E. Floreta Faber:
Honorable--
Honorable Minister Bushati,
Honorable Congressman
[Inaudible],
Honorable Congressman Engel,
coming also Senator Gary Peters,
Deputy Assistant
Secretary Hoyt Yee,
acting Deputy Librarian
[Inaudible],
Excellency ambassadors,
dear Albanian community,
dear colleagues of the
embassy of Albania,
let me wish happy
Albanian National Day
and Happy Armed Forces.
I use every chance to
present Albania as a new
and modern country and
also as one of the oldest
and ancient nations in Europe.
Today, we have a great chance to
see how this actually is true.
The building of the Library of
Congress has beautiful pieces
of Albania and has a very
dedicated Albanian corner.
As of now, it will also
contain one of the jewelries
of Albanian heritage,
the Codex of Berat.
We meet very often together
and I'm so happy I see
so many friends and
colleagues here,
so but I will leave the floor
to all our honorable
guests for their speeches.
If I can have the
attention, Minister Bushati,
Deputy Assistant
Secretary, Congressman Engel,
I would really be honored
if I can invite you
all here on the floor.
[ Applause ]
Deputy Assistant Hoyt Yee.
>> Rep. Eliot Engel:
Good afternoon,
I'm Congressman Eliot
Engel of New York,
I am the ranking
member on the house
of foreign affairs committee,
and I've had a love affair
with Albania since I first
went there back in 1993.
I've been there many
times since,
probably about 15
or 20 times since.
And I can tell you, you
can go all around the world
and visit all the countries
and all the continents,
and people will never be
more friendly to Americans
than the Albanian people.
And I know I've said
this many times,
and many times people
have agreed with me.
You know it's really a very
important story that Albania
after World War II had
a repressive government
and a government that
really sold the people
on anti-Americanism and it
was a communist government.
And what was really
very interesting to me
when I first came to Albania,
again in 1993, was it was clear
to me that the Albanian
people bought none of it.
They didn't believe any of it.
And that again, despite
all these things,
the Albanian people remained
as friendly to American people
as any place in the world.
And finally, let me say the
wonderful Albanian Diaspora we
have here in the United States,
people from Albanian but also
from Kosovo and also from
Macedonia and Montenegro,
they all have contributed
so much to American culture
and the American opportunity
that it really does me well
and of course in my home
district in New York,
we have many, many Albanian
Americans and I have many,
many Albanian friends,
including our ambassador here.
And so we just had a
flag raising in Yonkers,
New York a few days
ago, 105th anniversary
of Albanian independence.
We had a nice flag raising.
And so I want to be here
and be part of this,
it means a great deal to me.
Because in all the times
I've been to Albania,
each time I come it gets
better and better and better.
It's a budding democracy,
it's a member of NATO,
it's just making
so much progress.
And working together, our two
countries, we will continue
to make progress not only
in terms of friendship
between Albania and the
United States, but in terms
of Albania's place in the
world, again, as a strong ally.
And we're going to keep
fighting to get Albania
into the European Union,
where Albania belongs.
So I'm very happy to say
that this is a great
celebration right here
in this wonderful building.
This is my 29th year in
congress, and the work
that I've done with Albania has
been among the most treasured
work that I've done.
So thank you, "faleminderit."
[ Applause ]
>> Eni Jucja: You can join
us, congressman, senator.
Yeah, we announced that
you would be coming.
>> Sen. Gary Peters: Well,
good morning everyone.
It is wonderful to be here.
I'm US Senator Gary Peters,
representing the great state
of Michigan, which
is a wonderful honor.
But it is just as equal an honor
to really represent an
incredibly vibrant Albanian
American community in
the greater Detroit area.
We're blessed with one of
the largest communities,
I think second only to New
York, Eliot, in Michigan,
so I've had the opportunity
to work closely with
that community.
And the one thing I
learned in dealing
with Albanian Americans is
that once you go to an event,
you are part of the family
from that point forward.
You have just incredible
warmth, incredible hospitality,
and just a genuine
friendship that is very unique.
There are other communities that
are like that, but I will say
from my experience
there's nothing
like the Albanian
American community.
Although I don't believe I
have any bloodline to Albania,
I believe that I am
part Albanian now
because of all the work
with the community.
I've had the privilege of
working with Eliot Engel here,
it's great to see you, Eliot.
We actually had a
chance to travel together
to both Albania and Kosovo.
We cut the ribbon for
the wonderful highway
that connects the two
countries as well at that time.
Certainly Eliot has been
a champion for many years
as a co-chair of the
Albanian Caucus there.
And I also learned
traveling with Eliot,
he's like a rock
star in Albania, too.
It was amazing the attention
from all the work that you do,
it's a tribute to his
passion for the relationship
between our two countries.
I took the work, I was in the
Albanian caucus with Eliot
in the House, and then
when I came to the Senate,
I found that they didn't have an
Albanian caucus in the Senate.
I go okay, the Senate's got
a lot of good things going,
but the fact that it doesn't
have a caucus, that's a problem.
So we changed that, we now have
an Albanian American caucus
in the United States Senate.
I'm a co-chair with Senator
Ernst from Iowa, the republicans
and democrats coming together.
We hope that that continues to
be a strong, bipartisan caucus
to make sure we educate our
follow members in the US Senate
as to how important
this relationship is
and when you have an
important relationship,
you have to keep working at
that relationship to make sure
that it continues to
get stronger and better.
And it's clear that
the relationship
between our two countries
is strong.
I see a number of folks
here from the military.
When the US military goes into
harm's way and we're looking
for allies to assist us in those
efforts, Albania is always one
of the first countries that
raises its hand and says,
"We will be there, we will fight
for democracy, we will fight
for freedom, we will
fight for liberty."
Thank you to the Albanians all
across the world for what you do
for the cause of
liberty and freedom.
And I've seen that with other
groups that I've had the chance
to work with, including a
number of Iranian exiles
who were finding a difficult
place and didn't know
where to live and where to land,
and it was to the graciousness
of the Albanian community
and the Albanian people
that brought them into Albania
to give them a home
that is secure.
So thank you for letting
me come here to join
in this great celebration
for this day, for Albania
and for the Albanian
people across the country,
know you have a friend in
me and you're having more
and more friends each and
every day in the US Senate.
I'm confident that
this great relationship
between our two great countries
will only become stronger
and more vibrant
in the years ahead.
Thank you and congratulations.
[ Applause ]
>> Hoyt Brian Yee: Ladies and
gentlemen, members of Congress,
my name is Hoyt Yee, I'm
from the state department.
It's a great honor
to be here today.
I want to thank all
of you for coming.
I want to thank the members
of Congress and the librarian
from the Library of Congress
for allowing us to be here
in this beautiful member's room
of the Thomas Jefferson building
to celebrate this
important occasion.
It's really a great honor
to, along with my friends
from the Senate and House of
Representatives, to celebrate
with you this important
day, to express on behalf
of my government and
the American people,
our very best wishes
to the Albanian people.
This is indeed an occasion
for first, a celebration,
celebrating 105 years
of your independence,
but also at least a quarter
century of successful
and fruitful cooperation with
the United States in a dynamic
and growing stronger
every day friendship
between the United
States and Albania.
There's much to celebrate.
Your progress towards
integration with Europe,
your joining the European
Union, to look forward
to your joining NATO, which
you've already achieved.
But also setting an
example for the region
of looking forward,
not backwards.
Of building a future for your
young people with opportunity,
with jobs, with the prospects
of yet better things to come.
It's appropriate that we're
in the Thomas Jefferson building
celebrating this special day.
Thomas Jefferson wrote in a
letter to John Adams in 1816,
"I like the dreams
of the future better
than the history of the past."
And I think we can celebrate
with you, the people of Albania,
your success in looking forward
and in building this
better future.
We hope that the United
States will continue,
we expect that we
will, we promise you
that we will continue working
with you to realize this dream
of a better future, with even
closer integration with Europe,
even more security within NATO,
with stronger rule of law,
democratic institutions,
prospects for your young people.
This is also an occasion
for expressing gratitude.
And I want to join my colleagues
in expressing our gratitude
for what Albania has done
for the United States,
the NATO alliance, the
region, for Europe,
for our 25 year friendship.
Our political, economic,
and people to people ties are
growing stronger every day.
And we're deeply grateful to
Albania for the contributions
to our shared security
and prosperity.
To NATO missions in
Afghanistan, Kosovo, and Latvia.
But also as a close partner
in the global coalition
to defeat ISIS.
Albania is indeed an example
for the region as a center
of stability and
regional cooperation.
We welcome Albania's regional
leadership in the suffer
of countering trans-national
threats, such as terrorism
and violent extremism.
And domestically, internally,
Albania's also set an example
for countries in
the region trying
to achieve the same dream.
With the passage of sweeping
constitutional amendments last
year advancing judicial reform.
These types of reforms
will bring you closer
to Europe Union, it will
attract more foreign investment.
Such reform underscores a
shared value that we have,
our two countries, that
a strong partner is one
in with there is judicial
independence guided by the rule
of law, with strong democratic
institutions firmly in place.
Finally, this is an occasion
for reaffirming commitments.
And I want to reaffirm the
United States' commitment
to Albania.
The Secretary Tillerson wrote
in his statement on the occasion
of your national day, "Albania
is a valued friend and ally,
and the United States
looks forward
to your continued progress
towards greater Eur-Atlantic
integration and EU membership."
So thank you again for your
friendship and partnership
to the United States
throughout the years.
Mr. Minister, I took note of
your comments yesterday saying
that you wanted to see even
more US presence in the Balkans.
And I just want to say I share
with you a saying we have
in the United States, "Be
careful what you wish for,
because you might just get it."
Mr. Minister, we are
present in the Balkans,
we intend to continue to provide
our assistance, our support,
good diplomacy, trade,
commerce, shared security,
shared responsibility.
We look forward to continuing
to deepen these ties,
which the next 25
years of friendship
and close cooperation
will surely bring.
Finally, just to say,
"Gezuar Diten e Pavaresise."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> H.E. Ditmir Bushati:
Good afternoon, dear members
of Congress, dear [inaudible],
[inaudible], dear Hoyt.
I would like to start by
thanking you all for being here,
I wish you all a
Happy Independence
and Armed Force day.
To me personally, this is a
unique occasion in the sense
that we represent a
fragment of our culture
to the greatest library
in the world.
As Albanians worldwide
celebrated our Independence
and Armed Force day,
an independence
which would have not been
possible without the role
of United States of America for
which we are forever grateful.
Today, US and Albania are allies
and have a strategic
partnership.
Our partnership is based
on common interest,
similar viewpoints of
security in Europe,
and the trans-Atlantic
community,
shared values and beliefs.
Even though our democratic
institutions have shorter life
than the American institutions
and even though our democratic
culture is less robust
than the American one,
our shared values center
around openness, tolerance,
rule of law, and justice.
This legacy of our nation is the
first reason we celebrate today.
What a better story to
demonstrate these values
than the purple Codex of
Berat that are becoming part
of digital archive
of the library today
and part of UNESCO protected.
Created in the sixth
century before Christ,
the Codex are now part of
world heritage and starting
from today will be
part of the Congress
of Library [inaudible]
work of Albanian diplomat
and intellectual [inaudible]
and other luminaries
of Albanian Diaspora.
These Codex show that despite
the short and precarious life
of the Albanian state
and state institutions,
the Albanian culture
and its openness
to the Western civilization has
been longer and well documented.
This is something to celebrate
and be deeply grateful today.
The second thing I would like
to celebrate today is the
deep-seated partnership and
strong ties between Albania
and the United States
of America.
They do go back to our
history of state formation.
And extend to today's
US contribution
to Albanian path
of democratization.
The US has played a
strong role in one
of our key domestic reforms
in the past two years,
which is reform in
the judiciary sector.
Alongside the EU member states,
the United States is helping
with the implementation of
this comprehensive reform,
which has repelling
effect in a number
of other sectors,
not less the economy.
United States are present in
the Western Balkans and Albania
in particular through
their support
in strengthening
the rule of law.
We want this engagement to
continue, as we strongly believe
that if Albanian institutions
are resilient and rule
of law is strong, we
can contribute more
and in a more qualitative
way to stability and peace
in Western Balkans and more
broadly, to security in Europe
and the trans-Atlantic
community.
Today, while is the day
of Albanian Armed Forces,
this is also an occasion
to celebrate Albania's
contribution to security.
Even though a small country,
Albania stands alongside
the United States
in the joined fight against
terrorism, radicalization,
and violent extremism.
Our specific history
of religious tolerance is a
special asset which we put
in the service of prevention
of these phenomena
and global threats.
The US can also play a strong
role in the economic development
in Albania by permitting
connectivity, investing more
in strategic sectors, such as
infrastructure, energy, tourism,
and agriculture, we are creating
a more positive environment
for the US to be more
present in the region
and in Albania in particular.
Albanian Diaspora is
now a success story
of our two nations'
relationship.
The Albanian community in
United States plays a vital role
in the Albanian state formation
and in the economic
development of our country.
But they also contribute
to the economic, cultural,
and political life
of the US, too.
A third reason to celebrate
today is how far Albania
and Albanians have come.
From a small, weak,
and dependent state
in its early days,
to an isolated regime
in the post-communist
years to [inaudible] years
of post-communism married
by corruption crime
and informality, not to mention
weak social cohesion and trust,
Albania is now moving
ahead and thriving amidst
and against many challenges.
I don't want to sound
overly optimistic,
but the overarching
reforms we have undertaken,
the economic potential of our
country, and most importantly,
the energy, the drive, and the
[inaudible] of young people
in Albania makes me
believe in the future ahead.
The enthusiasm and the
interest in politics.
The engagement of Albanian
students to do part
in the Albanian day in DC
this week confirm my faith
that we will be able to write
a better story together.
I hope and believe that
our friends and allies,
the United States, will
be part of that story.
Thank you again for
the warm welcome
and Happy Independence Day,
"Gezuar Diten e Pavaresise."
[ Applause ]
>> H.E. Floreta Faber: Now I
would like to invite everyone
to enjoy the food and
the drinks and the party.
Thank you!
Thank you for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.